es ist die Silvester Schande von Berlin
marodierende Horden von ganz überwiegend
jungen Männern Migranten sind durch die
Stadt gezogen haben in der
Silvesternacht Rettungskräfte
angegriffen Passanten angegriffen haben
die mit Böllern attackiert haben
Gegenstände geschmissen da flog auch mal
ein Feuerlöscher auf einen Krankenwagen
da wurden Autos in Brand gesetzt da
steht ein abgebrannter Bus plötzlich rum
ja das sind 10 die man normalerweise
eher aus Krisen oder gar Kriegsgebieten
kennt so etwas mitten in der deutschen
Hauptstadt in unserem in unserer
Nachbarschaften das ist entsetzlich das
ganze Land diskutiert im Grunde über
dieses Szenen jetzt praktisch jeder weiß
was dort passiert ist aber ausgerechnet
unter Journalisten bei den
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen weiß man das
offensichtlich nicht was da passiert ist
oder man will es nicht sagen da gibt's
einige Beispiele dafür z.B die
Tagesschau haben geschaltet einen
Reporter und Fragen den was weiß man
denn über die Täter und der Mann sagt
doch tatsächlich einfach nur ja es ist
ja schwierig da jetzt über Täter zu
sprechen naja das waren wohl
gruppendynamische Prozesse da muss ich
mich auch fragen wie kann das bitte sein
dass das was jedes Kind sehen kann was
jedes Kind sagen kann was jedes Kind
aussprechen kann ausgerechnet dann
ausgebildeter Journalist sich nicht
traut zu sagen das ist natürlich
verheerend dann werden irgendwelche
Experten geschaltet die das erklären mit
na ja Corona lockdowns die Leute hatten
ja irgendwie und so weiter auch das ist
eine sehr seltsame Erklärung wenn das
Stichwort Migration was in dem
Zusammenhang offensichtlich eine große
Rolle spielt nicht fällt es geht weiter
auf tagesschau.de da ist doch
tatsächlich die Behauptung erschienen
die meisten Täter sind deutsche dieser
Tatverdächtigen das ist schlichtweg
falsch das stimmt nicht die meisten
Täter sind Ausländer ich scheue mich
auch nicht dass hier so klar zu sagen
denn wenn jemand nicht deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft hat dann ist er ein
Ausländer es ist ganz normal es tut
nicht weh das auszusprechen warum die
Tagesschau hier etwas berichtet was
schlichtweg nicht stimmt ist mir ein
Rätsel ein weiterer Fall ist passiert in
den Tagesthemen da berichtet ein
Feuerwehrmann davon wie seine Kollegen
und er angegriffen wurden von einem
mobben Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund er sagt das auch
aber die Tagesthemen zensieren den Satz
einfach knallhart wegschneiden einfach
vorher ab damit der Satz überwiegend
Migrationshintergrund damit dieser
Ausdruck einfach nicht fällt seine
gesamte Aussage ist wiederum
ausgestrahlt worden im rbb deswegen
wissen wir was er dort noch uns zu sagen
hatte aus den Tagesthemen sollten wir
das ganz offensichtlich nicht erfahren
das ist ganz überwiegend Migranten waren
die ihn angegriffen hatten was die ARD
sich da geleistet hat ist ein
journalistischer total Ausfall
offensichtlich ist vielfach der
Zuschauer besser informiert als
diejenigen die die Nachrichten machen
die nämlich entscheiden dass wir
bestimmte Dinge nicht wissen sollen oder
sie einfach weglassen natürlich merken
die Menschen das aber es ist auch ein
großes Problem weil gesellschaftlich
diese Schwierigkeiten die wir damit der
Migration haben natürlich diskutiert
werden müssen die müssen gelöst werden
auch in der Politik und diese Art von
Berichterstattung vernebelt die Realität
eher als dass sie sie sichtbar macht